So what happens when a major Supreme Court ruling puts a state's gun law under a whole
new legal microscope? Today, we're diving into a legal challenge arguing that a Massachusetts
firearm ban is unconstitutional. And what's fascinating is, the argument isn't about what
the law bans, but how it bans it. It's a case that all comes down to a new history-focused test
that could literally change everything. Alright, so here's our game plan. First,
we'll look at the specific Massachusetts law that's in the hot seat. Then,
we'll jump to the Supreme Court case that totally rewrote the rules. After that,
we'll unpack the new legal test it created, see how it's being applied in this case,
and finally get to the brief's powerful conclusion. So, let's start with the basics.
What exactly is this Massachusetts law that's at the center of this whole fight?
Okay, so at its very core, the challenge is about something the legal brief calls
temporal classifications. Sounds complicated, right? But it's actually pretty simple.
Imagine two people own the exact same firearm, identical in every way. For one person,
it's perfectly legal. For the other, it's a felony. The only difference between them is the
date they bought it. Next up, let's talk about the earthquake, the 2022 Supreme Court decision
that changed the game entirely. We're talking about the Bruin decision. For decades, courts used
this kind of balancing act called means and scrutiny. You know, they'd weigh the government's
interest in public safety against an individual's rights. Well, Bruin came along and just tossed
that entire framework out the window. Now, the new and only test is based on just two things,
the Constitution's text, and the nation's historical tradition of gun regulation.
And you can really see the court's new thinking in this quote from Justice Thomas,
who wrote the majority opinion. He's essentially arguing that the interest balancing was already
done back when the people ratified the amendment. So in his view, it's not a judge's job anymore
to weigh the public safety benefits of a gun maw because the Constitution already made that choice.
Okay, so with that old balancing act gone, what does this new text and history test
actually look like? How do courts even use it? Well, it boils down to a pretty straightforward
two step process. First, a court asks if the Second Amendment's plain text even covers
the conducting question, like say owning a handgun for self-defense. If the answer is yes,
then bam, the burden flips entirely to the government. They now have to prove that their
modern law is consistent with how firearms were regulated way back when the amendment was written.
And here is a super critical detail the brief points to which actually comes from an earlier
Supreme Court case called Heller. For a weapon to be unprotected by the Second Amendment, it can't
just be dangerous. It has to be both dangerous and unusual. That and is everything. It means the
weapon isn't in common use by the public for lawful purposes. Now we get to the heart of it all,
applying this grand new historical test to that Massachusetts law. This is where it gets really
interesting. And here's the key pivot in the whole argument. It's not actually about the guns
themselves. The brief claims the way the law works. Its very mechanism is unconstitutional.
They argue there's simply no historical precedent, no historical analog,
for a law that makes an identical object legal one day and illegal the next based on a date.
This table just lays out what the brief calls a constitutional absurdity. I mean, look at this.
Firearm A and Firearm B are identical in every single way. But because one was bought before
the cutoff date, it's legal. The other, bought just one day later, could land you in prison.
The argument is that this creates two classes of citizens with different rights,
based on nothing more than a date on a calendar. Now the Bruin decision was very specific about
which history actually matters. Courts have to look for similar regulations from two key periods.
Around 1791, when the Second Amendment was ratified, and 1868, when the 14th Amendment
applied those rights to the states. And according to this legal brief, when you go digging through
the history books from those eras, you find nothing. No laws that use this kind of date-based
grandfathering mechanism. So to sum up the brief's position, it argues the law fails the Bruin test
for a bunch of reasons. There's no historical twin for this kind of ban. It creates these totally
arbitrary classifications of people and property. It raises serious equal protection concerns.
And as a final point, it notes that many of the historical gun control laws that did exist
were often explicitly racist, which means they can't be used as valid examples today.
So where does all this lead us? What's the final takeaway from this entire legal analysis?
The bottom line is pretty direct. The brief concludes that the Massachusetts law is unconstitutional
under this new Bruin standard. Not because of what it bans, but because of how it bans it.
Since there's no historical tradition for creating different legal statuses for the
exact same object based on a date, the method itself fails the new constitutional test, plain and simple.
Ultimately, this legal challenge shows how one of the country's strictest gun laws is now on
really shaky ground, all thanks to a complete rewrite of the constitutional rulebook. And it
leaves us all with a much bigger question, right? With history now as the sole measuring stick,
what other modern laws, gun-related or not, might fail a journey into the past?